value what valuetainment or valuetaining
valuetaining this is valuetaining
now i'm getting into my reporter voice
on saturday march 12th the group of
dissidents were exposed
this is james o'keefe valuetaining
questions with an american muckraker
the final muckraker muckraker we define
it as someone who makes disclosures
releases information that's unauthorized
that they print something that powerful
people do not want printed because most
people in media and journalism journals
in these days relay information to the
public
that they want you to know we want to
publish information they don't want you
to know what was the most complex
character you played we set up a fake
website and met with these two npr
executives and presented ourselves as
agents with the fundamentalist muslim
brotherhood trying to make a 5 million
donation to npr
in order to elicit statements out of
this
vice president of fundraising for
national public radio and set up a
hidden camera inside the washington dc
restaurant and then the national public
radio ceo resigned what situation were
you most concerned for
it's never my physical safety it's
almost like my legal safety i've been in
jail i've been in handcuffs a few
different times by federal agents i've
been shackled the fear of being put in
chains and shackles that's that's not a
literal threat to your safety but going
to jail is no fun and uh arguably
that would be probably the biggest
threat to me physically is being
incarcerated what do you think the
future journalism should be
it's going to require
people who are non-credentialed
journalists people who are just citizens
people who don't go to journalism school
who are not working for a corporation
corporations
are for-profit and therefore are
compromised they can't tell the truth
because they have an ulterior motive
which is to generate a profit and if
your
goal is to generate a profit if that's
what you want to do you're not going to
do investigative reporting because it's
very expensive
if you could have dinner with any
historical figure who would it be and
why winston churchill
i would love to know
about his resilience which tv show
character do you most identify with
borat
has anyone ever told you you look like
drake bell i don't know who that is
what's the guy from
uh vision quest uh matthew modine that's
what andrew breitbart said to me what
song would you want to play in the
montage of your life we just did that
it's called the project veritas
experience blue sky action by above
what random stat of your life would you
want to know how many nights i've had
with eight hours of sleep
your guilty pleasure strawberry
haagen-dazs ice cream who has the
opposite opinion of you but you respect
them as a journalist that's a good one
glenn greenwald well who do you want to
play in the movie of your life a younger
version of matthew modine do mermaids
lay eggs or have babies that's a wild
question
you're stumping with that one
i don't know chicken or the egg on i'm
gonna i'm gonna say these names and just
say the first thing that comes to mind
it's like a cia interview go ahead go
ahead jake topper who's cnn anderson
cooper vanderbilt rachel maddow thor
hair tiger caller fox rush limbaugh the
abc bill o'reilly spin walter concrete
vietnam gene jock i can't say the word
because it would be inappropriate
what is this a cia interview
you guys planted that question
my staff was behind that question cnn
vice fox [ __ ] marry kill
i said well
can you say that again
this is wild this is this is unique i
have to say
say it again i'm gonna need like five
seconds to process what you just said
cnn
vice
fox
cnn vice and fox if you you're forcing
you to make a decision yes
this is this is an arbitrary decision
it's like a lottery i mean
it depends on what type of marriage you
want to have
i mean do you want do you want to be
with a borderline personality disorder
wife definitely here you can give me
many options here which one's the most
none of them are nurturing
the lord knows i need a patient woman in
my life
um i think i'd probably
have
i'd have sex with vice
i would um and then there's cnn and fox
and i have to either kill or marry one
or the other i'd probably kill cnn and
and
marry fox but not for the reasons you
would assume shameless book plug
american mock raker took me five years
to write this book it all
proceeds go to project veritas r51 and
if you want to read about
power and truth and
ethics and privacy and struggle and
sacrifice and endurance this book is a
is a non-fiction
story about what it means to be a
truth-teller in the digital age pick it
up americanmuckraker.com
[Music]